you can never be reminded too many times
about diagonal opposition
l fryer davis
good luck to you sir
thank you thank you gap thank you
we're gonna get a nice solid italian
game here it's a bunch of different
moves white can play
i've seen knight c3 here knight g5 d4 d3
castles
a bunch of different moves knight g5
very respectable move
very respectable
however
i like these lines i i quite enjoy
playing these lines as black
h6 knight f3
e4
95
bishop d6 d4
this is some very classic
i was gonna say this is some very
classic theory
but um
that looks like a mistake to me
it definitely looks like a mistake
question is
what
are we going to do about it
well i should certainly take this
this knight is very often a very bad
piece for black in these lines
and now
i think we're just gonna castle
and i'm assuming white is gonna do the
same
and now
guys do we have a greek gift
a classic greek gift
we gotta this has got to work right
this has got to be some theory
bishop takes h2
mountain ren what's up my man
great to see you here
great to see you
oh oh no
no way
it can't be right
it can't be right
cannot imagine that that is the correct
move
oh oh he doesn't even make me play it
out
resigns
i want to take a look at that though
yeah i'm pretty sure the mistake was
knight c4 yeah knight t4
knight takes c4 bishop takes c4
and yeah i mean i didn't see any huge
tactic here just castles
and if white castles then yeah you have
bishop takes h2 check
knight g4 check
king g1
king g1 tried
queen h4
rookie one
check
check
check
check
oh
no checking check like this yeah that's
the that is what i was calculating i was
calculating um
i was like i'm pretty sure queen takes
f2 check here is going to be winning
so what if king g3 i think i think i've
maybe even had this position before
queen d6
is best according to the computer queen
g5 scores much better though
and is a close second so i like queen g5
um it does run into
f4 or d4 though so d4
93 is checkmate in three
knight e3 check
king h2 queen takes g2 or you take okay
net e3 check
i did
i did actually see this line 93 check
um
[Music]
before i even
sacrificed my bishop i was like d4 93
check that looks pretty
good i stopped at 93 check though
and then there was one last one which
was f4 yeah f4 i think maybe
i feel like i've had like a very similar
position to this
but on poisson is forced of course
and then
gets actually not super clear for black
after that but obviously still very
winning